le personnel soignant continue à se
faire entendre notamment avec un
rassemblement devant le chu de bordeaux
une centaine d'infirmières un médecin un
aide soignant ou encore personnels
administratifs se sont rassemblés pour
faire entendre une nouvelle fois leurs
revendications
cette manifestation intervient alors que
le ségur de la santé a entamé son
quatrième jour de concertation le
personnel soignant espère que le
gouvernement entendra leurs demandes
d'écoutés
on a fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
manifestations avant deux piliers le coc
vide
personne n'a voulu rien entendre et
heureusement sur le subventionner eu de
la chance puisqu'on n'a pas eu une
grosse vague mais on était prêt si on
est à l'heure actuelle toujours prêt
mais si on avait pris en compte que lors
des manifestations selon avaient tous
dit on aurait pas eu tous ces sous
ces problèmes de masques soucis
personnels qui ont été impactés par le
coran que j'attends de la concertation
de ségur c'est que les jeunes aient
suffisamment envie de venir pour qu'on
puisse avoir suffisamment de bras pour
travailler et que ben en fait on est
plein de gens qui rêvent de faire notre
travail et non plus entendre les gens
qui disent ah non sept jours à l'hôpital
parce qu'à chaque reportage vont nous
dit à l'ats il ya des conditions
difficiles on a des jeunes qui s'en vont
on ne lâchera pas parce que bon ben il
ya un gros manque de personnel gros
manque de moyens de tout et nos
infirmières à bâle sont épuisés et tout
le monde est épuisé et je pense que ben
il faut qu'on se batte pour tout ça on
espère on espère que ça changera quelque
chose qu'on se mobilise pour quelque
chose n'est pas pour rien qu'ils vont
nous écouter